موسيقى
طفل ، لذا فهم يعودون إلى
أنهم يستعيدون طفولتك ، إنه لأمر
رائع أن
نرحب بالجميع في الذكرى 80 لتشارلز دبليو هوارد
بمدرسة سانتا كلوز
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من الأفضل أن تحذر من الأفضل ألا
تبكي  أنت لماذا بابا نويل ،
اسمي توم فيليت ، أنا عميد
مدرسة تشارلز دبليو هوارد سانتا كلوز في
ميدلاند ميشيغان ، هذه مدرسة هارفارد إيسانا ،
إنها أقدم مدرسة لسانتا
كلوز في العالم بدأها
تشارلي هوارد في عام 1937 في سانتا كلوز
في المدرسة تعلمنا كل شيء بدءًا من
الحفاظ على اللحية وحتى صناعة ألعاب النظافة الشخصية
وحتى الشعور بالركوب على متن
قطار Polar Express وهو يحلق على مزلقة ،
يجب أن يكون سانتا يتمتع بصحة جيدة ، فهو يتمتع بصحة جيدة في
الهواء الطلق إذا لم تكن بصحة جيدة.
لن
تنتبه ، من المهم جدًا أن تمتلك
جميع المهارات التي يمكنك أن تكون
بابا نويلًا رائعًا لأن الطفل
سيتذكر هذه الزيارة لبقية
حياتك عيد الميلاد
عندما كان تشارلي في المدرسة التي كان بها ثلاثة
أو أربعة طلاب  بعض السنوات الجيدة ، ربما
15 طالبًا هذا العام ، لدينا 214 طالبًا ، لقد زاد عدد الطلاب
لدينا بالطبع بالطبع من
كل ولاية تقريبًا في الولايات المتحدة ، لدينا
حوالي 20 سانتا من كندا ، لدينا
ثلاثة سانتا من الدنمارك ،
واحد من النرويج وواحد من ألمانيا
هناك حقيقي  إحساس الصداقة الحميمة في
هذه المدرسة ، يشبه اجتماع عائلة سانتا الكبيرة هذه
معًا ، حيث يتشاركون
القصص التي يتعلمونها من بعضهم البعض ،
نريد أن نكون بابا نويل لنجعل الناس سعداء
عندما نجتمع معًا ، فنحن نجعل بعضنا
البعض سعداء
، أحب ذلك بمجرد مغادرتهم هذه المدرسة
آمل أن يكون كل بابا نويل والسيدة.
يخرج كلوز وينشر روح
الكريسماس تنشر الحب والفرح الذي
لدينا هنا في هذه المدرسة
ويمررها إلى جميع الأطفال الصغار
وجميع العائلات عندما تمنح الفرح ، يمكنك
إعادتها إلى أضعاف